[Musique]
cuisinier m'entendez-vous
Roger rumeur l'équipage est dans mon infirmerie
après avoir mangé votre miraculeux piment de l'espace
idée ce que vous voulez dire
notre nourriture est saine vigoureux capitaine à l'
équipage singe mort dans le nid de pie
je répète singe dans l'espace chatons
frappe à nouveau copiez ce capitaine une page
où nous pourrions utiliser votre piment spatial pour
overclocker nos moteurs
negativo moi amor ne tirant que sur mon
cirque continuez à rire imbéciles
c'est trop bon
frappe commentez qu'avons-nous sur ce
rassemblement chuck merde
nada j'ai l'impression de voir quelque chose  la
star de l'heure libre est née c'est énorme mais
reviens ici Sonny retire
[Musique
] dans le dos hein
[Musique]
toi